[موسيقى]
انا بتصدق يا عم كل يوم بالليل عندنا
بردانين وجوعانين
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
نستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
الذي صنع التاريخ وتاهل الى نصف نهائي كاس
العالم بعد تغلبه على البرتغال في مباراه
مثيره ليكون بذلك اول منتخب عربي يصل الى
هذا الدور كما تاهلت الارجنتين بعد فوزها
على هولندا بركله التي الترجيح وكرواتيا
التي اخرجت البرازيل من المونديال براكه
لا تتريح ايضا معظم زملاء في القسمه
الرياضيهم والانه في محيط الملاعب ومناطق
المشجعين ولكن مسؤول للقسم حيدر عبد الحق
موجود هنا يا مرحبا كيف حالك شو اخبارك
يعطيكم العافيه
حيدر ما الذي يمكن قوله عن الدور الربع
النهائي في مونديال قطر 2020
اثاره كبيره حدثت في هذه البطوله والدور
ربع النهائي ودور الحصول على الكاس بدايه
المشوار للحصول على الكاس في الفرق
الثمانيه الموجوده همم تحاول الحصول على
الكياس وبالتالي هناك اربع فرصه تغادر
واربع فراغ تبقى في قطره حتى نهايه
البطوله لانه حتى اللي يخسر على نصف نهائي
يلعب على الثالث والرابع والفائزين يلعبون
على مباراه النهائي اذا الفراق الان تبحث
عن الكاس منذ هذا الدور وشهاده مباريات
جميله جدا ومثيره جدا وخاصه مفاجاه ساره
المنتخب المغربي ههه شكرا يتقاتل العافيه
حيدر بالتوفيق ومثل ما قيل كثيرا مونديال
قطر
المقاييس فقط التنظيم وانما حتى في في
اللعب في الفرق المشاركه شكرا شكرا شكرا
شكرا شكرا نتركه
الرياضيه التي تتابعونها بالتاكيد على
شاشه الجزيره
تصيد جديد ومستمر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
خلال الاسبوع الماضي حيث شهدت الضفه
الغربيه موجه اقتحامات اسرائيليه راح ضحيه
الاشتباكات فيها عدد من الشهداء خمسه منهم
خلال 24 ساعه فضلا عن حمله اعتقالات واسعه
رئاسه الفلسطينيه اتهمت تل ابيب بالسعي
لاشعال المنطقه في حين اعلنت حماس التمسك
بالمقاومه التصعيد الاسرائيلي المتواصل في
الضفه العكس غضبا وتمديدا عال من الصلاه
لنلقي نظره على ابرز يتفاعلات ادهم ابو
سلميه يقول تمارس اسرائيل امام سمع العالم
وبصره عمليه قتل المنظم للشباب
الفلسطينيين اعدامات مروعه تتم كل يوم
العالم الظالم الذي يصمت على جرائم
اسرائيل يتحرك حين يحاول الشباب والدفاع
عن انفسهم اما الدكتور نادر شوقي فيقول
سلوكه لاخت يعكس وياسه من المقاومه في
الضفه يلجا الى محاوله اشباع نزوات جنوده
بالقتل كل ذلك ينعكس اصرارا من
الفلسطينيين على المقاومه اما في تطورات
ملف اغتيال يا زميله شيرين ابو عاقلين فقد
اعلنت شبكه الجزيره رفع القضيه امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وسط رفض
اسرائيلي ودعوات لطرد صحافيين الشبكه
استضافه الرياض ثلاثه قمم قمه خليجيه وقمه
خليجيه صينيه وقمه عربيه صينيه غير مسبوقه
شدت على تطوير العلاقات اللي استراتيجيه
فيما تحدث الرئيس الصيني عن عصر جديد
للعلاقات مع العالم العربي وكان لافتا
تاكيده على دعم قيامه دوله فلسطينيه
عاصمتها القدس على حدود عام 67 مراسلون
عدنان البوريني وكباب تلك الاحداث سوريا
مرحبا عدنان ما الذي يمكن قوله عن كواليس
هذه القمم
وما الذي ركزت عليه نعم محمد انتهى يوم
اني حافلان من الدبلوماسيه هنا في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض روماني حافلاني بدا
بزياره الرئيس الصينيشي الى هنا حيث شهدت
الرياض ثلاثه قيمه من متتابعه قمه صينيه
سعوديه قيمه خليجيه صينيه وقمه عربيه
الصينيه هذه القمم الثلاثه تحاول او حاول
فتح اخر جديده للعلاقات اعتبرتها بجين اهم
واكبر نشاطا دبلوماسيه في تاريخها مع
العرب وهي حاولت بحسب الرئيس الصيني فتح
مستوى جديد من العلاقات يركز بشكل او باخر
على البعد الاقتصادي والبعد التنموي
والبحث ايضا عن مساحه مشتركه في السياق
الاقليمي
شكرا جزيلا لك عدنان المانيا كانت في
صداره الاحداث فقد اعلنت الحكومه احباطها
مخطط
بيهدفوا للاستيلاء على السلطه حيث اعتقلت
الشرطه اشخاصا ينتمون لحركته مواطني
الرايخ وهي منظمه يمنيه لا تؤمن بحدود
الدوله الالمانيه الحاليه وكانت تنوي
انشاء جيش موازن وتنفيذ هجمات والاستلاء
على مباني رسميا زميلنا عيسى طيب موجود
حاليا
فيرج التي تعد معقله مواطن الرايخ نتصل
بعيسى
يا مرحبا عيسى ما هو حجم الخطر الذي شكله
هذا الكرش
الالماني قال بان هذه المنظمات
الدوله بقوه السلاح بمعنى اخر انقلاب مسلح
الدموي هذا هو المخطط الذي علمته هذا
التنظيم الامر الثاني وهو ان الاستخبارات
الداخليه الالمانيه اكدت بان عديد من
الافراد هم من خريجين الجيش الالماني
مهارات عاليه ايضا السلاح هو الجزء القادم
من مخزونات الجيش الالماني
شكرا عيسى يعطيك الصحه رغم القطيعه
الدبلوماسيه شهد الاسبوع الماضي صفقه
تبادل سجناء بين امريكا وروسيا شملت رجل
الاعمال الروسي فيكتور فوت المعروفه بتاجر
الموت ولاعبتا كره السله الامريكيه بريتني
براينر السعوديه والامارات اعلنتا نجاحه
وسطتهما لاتمام التبادل في حين نفل بيت
الابيض ذلك اذا رجل اعمال مقابله لاعبه
كره سله في التعليقات تجدون فيديو يقدم
لكم المزيد عن خبايا هذه الصفقه النادره
في اجراء عقابيا غير مسبوق ضد موسكو
مجموعه الدول السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا اتخذت قرارا بتحديد سقف ساريه
مستر روسي
واردات النفقه المنقوله بحرا من روسيا
الكريم لان رفض القرار واعلن عدم بيع
النفط لدول التي ستخضع له مشاهدينا على ان
من شانه اضراره باسواق الطاقه برايكم هل
هذه الخطوه ستؤثر علينا كمستهلكين ننتظر
تفاعلاتكم شكرا على متابعه في ايجاز
الاسبوعين القاكم الاسبوع المقبل بحول
الله اينما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]